Okay. So let's start. Welcome everyone
to lecture number two of the course.
Okay. So after setting sort of stage for
what we're going to do in the course,
let me sort of get going.
So quick recall. So if you remember so
the key aim of the course as I said is
that we are going to learn physics
and that physics is typically modeled by
differential equations in particular
partial differential equations PDEs and
we are going to do it using data. So
these are the key words in the course
physics, data, PDEs and the last element
which is what I stopped in the last
lecture are neural networks because this
is sort of the key point or the key sort
of foundation of modern machine
learning. So modern ML is all about
neural networks. Okay.
>> Is
we are going to look at how neural
networks can be leveraged, how they can
be used in order to together with data.
So you have data
plus uh neural networks
and this is going to be used to learn
physics.
uh this is modeled by PDS right so this
is the loop so what we're going to do is
to see how these guys can be useful in
this context but we'll find out also
that uh we also need to know a little
bit about physics in order to be able to
do this right but without further ado
let me uh give you a very very brief
intro on what neural networks are these
days everyone knows what they are I
assume that all of you have seen them
but just in case someone hasn't and just
to set the notation to have a general
start a general introduction to the
course what I'm going to do is to
provide you a very brief overview of
what neural networks are okay so as the
name suggests neural networks uh
originate from neuroscience right
because it's neural networks they come
from the neurons in the brain and just
to give you a brief history of how the
field started you might have seen this
before but uh please bear with
So the idea is in the during the second
world war in 1943
uh McCullik and Pitts these are
experimental neuroscientists. This was
the very beginning of neuroscience. You
know before that people didn't really
have a sense of what neuro neurology is
what neuroscience is how brain works how
the nerves work how the entire nervous
system works and so on. So if you
remember from your high school biology
if you have taken it that the biological
neurons so first of all neurons are
nerve cells they are in our brain for
instance is composed of neurons and
that's not just not true of our brains
but brains of many many animals right so
the idea behind a neuron is that it has
this sort of very specific structure
with nucleus which is so this is the
central part and then there are all
these sort of communicating channels so
these are dendrites and ax exons and so
on and the entire sort of communication
between neurons. This one neuron by
itself processes only a bit of
information, very little of information.
But the entire sort of structure in
neurology brain function emerges by
communication by sort of uh let's say
communication between neurons
communication and this is all electrical
in nature. Right? So the signal
processing is completely electrical
analog signal processing. Right? So
there's a lot of electrical transmission
and out of this electrical transmissions
uh you get the emergence of thought for
instance a very complex brain functions
and no one understands how this
originates right so this is still one of
the big biggest mysteries in science in
neuroscience at least so this is a
biological neuron and what these
gentlemen mulligan pets realized is that
you can actually write them model them
mathematically in a very very simple way
that each neuron in some sense can is is
is a is a processing machine is a
logical processing machine and the way
they thought of it is that it's what is
called logic unit. So let me just try to
elaborate on that. So these are logic
gates. So you can think of a neuron
function or action of a neuron as a
logic gate. This is a big abstraction
right? There's a lot of biology which
goes in a lot of cell biology a lot of
electrical signaling calcium channels
sodium channels this that I don't
understand. There's a lot of nuance here
but at the basic level what they argued
is that you can abstract all of this out
and you can condense this information
distill it into some very very basic
things. So let me try to explain what
that is right. So their point was that
you get some inputs. So let's say x1 and
x2 and you weigh them. This is where the
chemistry the neural chemistry in the
brain takes place. You weigh them. So
you weigh them in a linear manner or a
fine manner if you want to because you
can always add a bias. So this is the
way and then on top of it you have a
threshold right because bio biology is
all about thresholds. If certain signals
or certain chemicals are beyond a
threshold something's fire if they're
below a threshold it doesn't fire. So
this is like step function logic. So
their point was that what neurons do is
that at a very simple level they collect
inputs, they weigh them through these
chemical processes and they threshold
them, right? And they threshold them and
different kinds of logical gates for
instance and is based on just ascribing
the weights of one to these neurons. A
bias of minus2 and then a fire right one
or zero if it is below a certain signal.
if it is below zero.
Okay. Sorry people on Zoom. There was
some incident. Let's put it that way in
class. Okay. But uh I have not I barely
started. I have not done anything deep.
I'm just explaining how people think
individual neuron works. Right? So what
it does is that you can abstract out all
the chemistry, all the biology and it
ends up just being taking inputs,
weighing them in a very simple manner.
That is the sort of this is the basic
operation here and then having a firing
operation. So if it is certain below a
threshold then nothing happens. If it is
above a threshold the signal is
communicated further. Right? So that's
why it's called a threshold logic unit
because it relies on this threshold. And
as you can see, it's essentially a step
function at work. If something is below
a threshold, it's zero. Above a
threshold, it's it's one. And their
belief is that these weights were
adjustable. So these weights are right
here. I I just explained to you what
they are. So these weights here, W1 and
W2, these are adjustable, but they
didn't think of them as being learned.
So there was no learning process taking
place. But this is a biological
abstraction. Many neurobiologists will
laugh at this description. They will say
that this is doesn't take into account
any brain chemistry. It doesn't take
into account any biology, any evolution.
But it's a simple abstraction. And this
is what malog pits argued. But it can
still do some computation, right? It can
say it can use and or not. Different
kinds of logical operations can be done
through this very very simple
abstraction, very simple construction.
So then in 1957 after the second world
war Rosenlot so he is the he understood
this the best and he realized that what
you can do is it's not just about two
inputs it can be as many inputs as you
like finitely many of course but a lot
of them and these are weights so
remember so here there were two which
were being weighed and then they were
being thresholded all that Rosenblad did
is that uh he he abstracted out even
further that you can have multiple
inputs n little n number of inputs these
inputs are being weighted right with
this wi these weights there's a bias
that you can always add and then there
is a thresholding operation right and he
believes that this is sort of the
fundamental unit of neural computation
neural computation relies on this and he
called it as a perceptron so this is the
technology or the terminology that he
used so the point that he realized is
that this is something called an
activation function.
It's all biology, right? Because
activation is something is activated or
it's not activated. So this is this
threshold logic again. And you realize
that in principle these weights they are
not fixed because then if you fix them
then like in the last slide you can only
learn some finitely many things and or
not. But what he realized is that these
weights can be learnable. So based on
the data, based on the situation, based
on the context, you can change these
weights and this is more or less the
origin of modern artificial neural
networks. Okay. So you can also call
these as artificial neuronet networks. I
don't like the term but uh some people
use it neural networks orns.
Okay. So what is the construction? So
it's based on simple biology. You take
in inputs, you weigh them, you threshold
them. It's exactly the same. Multiple
inputs, multiple weights, and then
thresholding. And he realized that at
least in some very simple cases, you
could classify data into two classes.
For instance, positive, negative, left,
right, you know, something in the
picture, something not in the picture.
And he was able to even argue that
theoretically. So this was quite a big
bit of a change that the units of neural
computation could do this kind of
non-trivial computation within a way and
or not these are like trivial
computations right and a direct
descendant of this is what is called a
multi-layer so this you can think of it
as a perceptron or you can think of it
as a one layer perceptron one layer
perceptron okay this is just terminology
one layer because there's exactly one
sort of element or one logical unit that
is functioning all the computations. But
then if you stack it together, you get
what is called a multi-layer perceptron.
And this is going to be the bread and
butter of our work because today modern
deep learning uh somehow owes its origin
to multi-layer perceptrons. Even in the
chat GPT, believe it or not, there are
tons and tons of MLBs or multi-layer
perceptrons which are being used. And
the idea grammatic uh graphically
diagrammatically is exactly the same
that you have computation I have a slide
in the next uh which explains it even
better is that you just take each of
these units right and you stack them on
top of each other. So one hidden layer,
two hidden layers, three, four and this
is how the entire processing takes place
and in a way it is representative or
reminiscent of what happens with neurons
because you see that the transmission of
signals in our brain or [clears throat]
in our nerves is also sort of a
sequential process. Starts with neuron
one which communicates with neuron 2
which communicates with neuron 3 which
communicates with neuron four. There's a
lot of feed forward loops. There are
also feedback loops which this doesn't
take into account but this is where
there is a um let's say a divorce from
neurobiology right we don't care about
neurobiology once we'll this is just to
inspire what what actually goes on okay
so this brings us to the sort of the
main example or the simplest example of
a deep neural network which is going to
be the multi-layer perceptron right now
for some reason
Yeah,
multi-layer perceptron. And this is what
I'm going to explain. Let me start with
the formulas because then it's sort of
easier to explain and then we go back
and forth between the formulas and the
pictures. So essentially the way we
think of an MLB forget about the
neurobiological origins of it is that
it's essentially a mapping. So what is
the notation that I have used here?
Notation is FAR, right? So this is
essentially a mapping which takes some
input. So as you can see it's an input
X. I think I called it as uh zed but
okay sorry for the notational
problems but
let's take an input zed and it goes all
the way to an output f of z. So
mathematically it's just a function.
It's a very very simple function. Takes
a finite dimensional input and builds
into a finite dimensional output. Right?
And the way it does it is through a
sequence of uh steps. Right? Sequence of
steps like this. And the sequence of
steps are given in terms of this is just
my notation. Other people have different
kinds of notation. But in the course we
going to use this notation. So remember
this is my input. This is my output. So
far
takes uh Z which belongs to RD and it
goes to FAR of Z which belongs to R O.
Okay. So this is O for output. So this
is a very very simple construction and
the key point is that you do this by
using compositions. Okay. So if you re
recognize what is happening here, let me
use a different color is that we have
these compositions.
these compositions everywhere and we
stack them on top of each other, right?
So something like this. So these are
these uh let's say K layers, capital K
layers. So this is capital K
your layers. By the way, you can always
ask me questions either here or on Zoom.
Uh so this I'm always open to that,
right? And what is the construction of
each of these layers? So it's
essentially a composition. So you
compose the same things over and over
again. But what what is the unit of the
composition? The unit of the composition
are two things, right? So this is the CK
here. And the CK is a fine comp
function. Aphine means it has a linear
block, right? So you have a matrix
vector multiply and you add to it a
vector. Okay, that's it. So you have
been given a vector input Z K. ZK K
belongs to R DK I I believe here. So
it's a DK dimensional vector. You
multiply a matrix to it and this matrix
is DK + 1 * DK right? So the dimensions
add up. This becomes DK + one and then
you add another vector which is in DK +
1. So the output of this CK this FI. So
remember that CK is FI
and this is for each K right? So this is
a K layer it's a fine and the output is
going to be TK + one dimensional vector.
So this uh matrix that you multiply is
often called the weight matrix remember
from the neural networks these are this
one two and this is how we got the gates
and the vectors are called the bias
vectors okay it's a bias it sort of
shifts uh things around so that's the
first thing right but then there is
another unit here which is very very
important which is this sigma so in the
next slide I have a lot of information
about sigma but sigma essentially is a
scalar function so It maps um I don't
know a z or a perhaps to a sigma of a
and a is a scala. If you have any
questions you can always ask me. Don't
disturb the rest of the class. Okay. So
now this is the this is the composition.
This is it. This is a neural network,
right? It's a very very simple
construction. And the way we do it is
through these compositions. So remember
that this I'm going to talk a little bit
more about this in a second. This is
what is called an activation function.
Okay. So let's go back to the picture
that we have here. So we have these
compositions. So what we say here is
that this is your fine
aphine part and fine is always
multiplying a weight matrix wk with your
input plus a bias right and then an
activation function. An activation
function this is very important. Sigma
which is the activation acts component
wise
need not right but this is how our brain
works because thresholding is always a
scalar quantity you see a certain
chemical it's above a threshold you give
it a value one it's below a threshold
you give it a value zero you don't take
into account their interactions it turns
out that many people have realized that
maybe this is not the optimal way to do
it but it has stuck to us right so
remember that you have this Fine
nonlinearity scale and nonlinearity file
scale and nonlinearity fine scale and
nonlinearity and this is it. So you yes
go ahead
sigma of a also belongs to R. Sorry
you're good. Good point.
Yeah now my slide is getting denser by
by the second but maybe I I Yes. Go
ahead.
>> Did I understand right that always
starts with that kind of but can either
like the last day can both be an
exhibition function
>> or could be something else. I know this
is this is highly possible in your
exercises probably you already did this
but uh I will tell I'll tell about it
but in the simplest construction because
that is a detail right in the simplest
construction you start with an input
which is a vector high dimensional
potentially in fact today on a routine
these vectors could be as many as 10
million dimensions you know so 100
million dimensions in some videos and so
on but then you multip multiply this
weight matrix, you add a bias vector and
then you put this scala nonlinear. This
is always the case. Of course, you might
have it could be an identity and then uh
we you'll see I'll talk about the output
layer in a second.
>> So in the exercise it was one
transformation activation function
another transformation
>> and then an identical
>> yeah for the but for the smallest will
be enough just the layeration function
no second. No, no. You need another you
need a fine layer otherwise it's not
enough. So if you just have a
nonlinearity
I'll tell you I'll tell you what it's a
good question that you ask. If you just
have a nonlinearity then you will the
nonlinearity is usually a positive
nonlinearity and you want to approximate
negative functions for instance you'll
never be able to do that. So I I'll tell
you exact I have a slide about that. So
just just be patient but it's good that
you ask further questions. No, everyone
understands this. This is Derek these
days. So it's fine. Okay. So let me just
focus a little bit on the activation
functions and then I'll come to the
output layer and so on in a in a second.
So just some terminology these theta
this is so I take all the veins all
these are matrices right. So now there
are k matrices uh because each of these
layers have a matrix. So I put all of
them together in one bucket and
similarly all these vectors I put all of
them together in one bucket. So this is
I combine everything and this is what
are called parameters or tunable or
trainable parameters. But maybe I I'll
tell so think of this theta as being a
parameter. So essentially what a neural
network is is that it's a parametric
map. What does it mean? So let's uh
maybe explain it here. So you have a
mapping f of theta because remember that
I didn't tell you what these weights and
biases are. So there's a lot of choice
that one has regarding this, right? So
far of theta. So this f_star is nothing
but f_star of theta equals to f_star
because when you change the theta, you
have a different function. You change
theta again you have a different
function. So you have all kinds of
choices that are there in this uh in
this in this function. So it's a
parametric map. It's a compositional map
and the compositions itself are based on
very very simple objects. So just an
aphine layer or an aine step followed by
a scalar nonlinearity. So let me focus a
little bit more on this scalar function
this activation function. Remember that
it's a scalar as I said it's applied
component wise. So if you have a big
vector you take the and take this sigma
on top of this big vector then it's just
applying to each of these components
sigma of a1 sigma of a2 and so on and so
forth maybe I write so sigma applied to
a big vector x1 x2 up to x k is simply
equal to sigma of x1
sigma of x2
up to sigma of xk. So that is what
component wise means and what are the
examples. So now we have to make a
choice right what this activation
function is and there are hundreds of
thousands if not millions of possible
activation functions that you can take.
Millions is just a word I used. It could
be infinitely many of course. So the
simplest of course is the heavy side
function. If you remember when we did
the biological intuition it was always
the heavy side function because biology
is about thresholds. If you're above a
threshold, something fires. If you're
below a threshold, it doesn't. Right?
So, this is a heavy side function. You
can see that there are some issues with
it. And this is this goes back to
malogan bits.
But we realize very quickly that no one
uses this because uh you know it's it's
okay in biology that there are these
kind of biological processes. But the
way in which we work with this neuronet
networks, this is not going to be
suitable. So this is not a good good
activation function but you can
approximate it right if it's a sharp
step is bad you can always sort of
modify the step and here is an example
where you modify it it's called a
logistic function so I have several so
this is as I said it's a smooth
approximation to the heavy side function
and it is what is called a sigmoid a
sigmoid is something which takes a value
of minus one at infin minus infinity and
one at infinity and in fact this is also
So people can use it. It's an example
logistic function or sigmoid function.
The one which is more often used and
what you we will use okay there's some
asymmetry but that's not the important
thing is the hyperbolic tangent. Okay
all of you know what the hyperbolic
tangent is. It's scaling or factor or
ratio of exponentials right and as you
can see it is approximating the step
function. It's a you can control it you
can make it. You can squash it together.
You can make it spread out. And actually
this is a this is first of all it's a
smooth function. It turns out that that
is going to be useful and actually we'll
use the hyperbolic tangent for instance
in the next lecture. So this is this is
a popular function but it's it's a very
popular activation function but it's not
the only one because the one that is
more heavily used these days or some
versions of it used is what is called
the relu function. So, ReLU is let me
write down because it's useful rectified
linear
unit. It doesn't look anything remotely
like this guy, right? But it turns out
that both of them are good choices.
You'll see in a sec why. And ReLU is
just a positive part of the function.
Okay? So, you take any function, you
squash the negative part to zero, just
retain the positive part and you get uh
ReLU. And there are some very good
things mean it's scale invariant and so
on. But the bad thing is again that you
don't have a gradient because here you
have zero here you have some unit
gradient. So the gradient is going to be
a step function. So what people have
used is some derivatives of relu. So
leaky relu and so on and so forth. So
there are tons of these kind of
functions and uh essentially the two
most widely sort of at least at at an
abstract level which are useful are
these two and we will always sort of use
some versions of them hyperbolic tangent
and rel
okay and you'll see in a in a sec in a
few in a few seconds why this choice of
activation function is important to some
extent and unimportant to some other
extent. many many different functions
can serve as activation functions. Okay.
So let's see that then we combine
everything right. So essentially what we
have ish back to the basics here. So as
maybe returning to his question the last
layer is always special because you can
also use identity often it's identity.
So sigma 0 can be identity
not necessary but uh it's it's it's good
to have it as an identity. So in some
other cases image classification for
instance this is what is a soft soft max
function but this is a detail. So
remember the important points are that
multiple layers. So first of all what is
a neural network or an artificial neural
network or MLP. So it takes a vector Z
could be very high dimensional. I said
nothing about the dimension of this
vector and then it goes all the way down
to an output which is also a vector
would be a scala for all I know of
probabilities but in general it's a
vector so it's a mapping right so
mathematically it's just a mapping a
function which takes a vector input and
produces a vector output so that's the
first thing it's not a mysterious object
it's just a function second thing is
that it's a composition so it you take
into account different layers in this
composition and in each layer pair
consists of just two simple parts, an
aphine piece, right? And a scalar
pointwise nonlinearity. That's it. And
these weights and biases, the parameters
of the neural network make it a
parametric map, right? So it's uh so
this is sort of the basic construction
to make it a parametric map. And this is
a parametric map that we're going to use
to learn from data. Okay. So very very
simple sort of explanation very very
simple throughput and yes go ahead
useful to have different activations.
>> You can also do that you can have
different activations for different
layers. You can learn the activations
you can you can write a paper by
changing the activation and there are
hundreds of thousands of such papers you
know so it's uh but it's not essential
already. This very simple construction
as you will see is good enough for most
purposes. So you can change it. There is
no this is not set in stone where you'll
see that all this this is just the basic
unit or upon which everything else is
built but we keep on changing it and
dropping it based on our needs or our
taste or just the need to write a paper
you could you could always do that. Yes.
And layer is necessary.
>> Uh the structure of the how these
matrices and how these vectors are can
change. But what what would you change
it to a nonlinearity or mean uh aine
means aine is the most general linear
function that you can think of. Right?
The idea is to take something linear
[clears throat] but this linear is sort
of combining different elements. is
mixing things. So it's not just about
linear, it's about mixing things. And in
the second stage, you don't mix, you
pass it through a nonlinearity. So if
you want a picture, this is what uh the
picture is the very first one I started
out with, right? So if you remember,
it's super this this is good enough,
right? So this is where the mixing takes
place.
So different neurons are sending in
inputs to our given neuron and it is
weighing them based on the chemistry. So
this is an aine you you cannot change in
you can make it a nonlinear mixing this
is this is always possible but we are
not going to do that because that just
adds complication and does not add
anything to how we mix matters right
because the structure even in this
lecture and throughout the course you
will see that we'll change the structure
of this weight matrix and this bias
vector that will change right but not
the basic basic structure and then each
of these inputs are put in through this
nonlinearity. So this will remain
intact, right? There's some
conservativity when it comes to this
particular construction.
Okay. So without further ado, let me
sort of explain some of the things with
I think in the next slide it's uh it
sort of explains what's going on. So
remember that all that a neural network
does is that it takes a finite
dimensional vector as an input and
produces a finite dimensional vector as
this is this is all that it does. And
there's a particular way of doing it
right through this linear and aphine. So
through this aphine and scalar
nonlinearity applied to it. Now why is
this making any sense right? Why do we
even care about this particular kind of
construction? Of course you can say that
it has been inspired by neurobiology but
in a very weak way because biology has a
lot of details that we have just thrown
out. We have made it very very abstract.
Right? And one reason why this is a
powerful construction or even a feasible
construction why we don't need anything
on top of it is because of what is
called a universal approximation theorem
and this is a very very important
property means people don't emphasize it
often enough but this is what gives us
the confidence that these objects make
sense. What do what do I mean by this
universal approximation theorem? So
remember that after all what is my far
theta? Okay, there is f* theta
is my neural network, right? MLB, let's
say MLBs. So now this is just a
parametric function which takes a input
and it produces an output. So now y is
just a vector space. What a universal
approximation theorem essentially does
and I'm going to walk you through this
entire slide is that it tells you that
if I have any function, what is a
function after all in this context? It
is a response between inputs and
outputs, right? So for instance, how
does the temperature change as a
function of space and time or how does
the pressure change as a function of
space and time and things like that. So
you could always incorporate them as
systemic responses. So this is what a
function does, right? It tells us how
things change. And now
what it tells is that whatever be the
complicated function that you give me
whatever as long as it has some
structure to it and that structure is
continuity or as you can see
measurability then there exists a neural
network or there exists weights and
biases such that I can approximate it.
So I can learn anything in principle
from this very very simple construction.
So just think of uh now let's uh this
appears mathematical but it's actually a
very simple intuitive idea. So what's
going on? So just imagine that y is just
some vector space. I'm looking at all
continuous functions of y means this is
the notational abuse because I didn't
tell you what the range is but this
doesn't matter. Think of all possible
functions right as long as they are
continuous. So continuous functions can
be very nice ones smooth functions. They
can be very rough ones like uh sawtooths
right or they can be very very oscilly
ones or nonossy ones any function right
so this is a very very large space that
you can imagine what the point is with
this universal approximation theorem is
that just these objects these sort of
compositions of simple aine units
together with scalar nonlinearities a
very very simple construction this is
good enough to approximate any of these
functions now you have seen this in your
basic Basic analysis all of you have
seen this um y approximation theorem
that if you take functions which are um
continuous functions you can approximate
them at polomials right so polomials are
what are called expressive or universal
or dense depending on what what
terminology that you use any function I
can find a polomial to approximate it I
of course need to go higher and higher
in the polinomial degree but I can do
that so just imagine that so for
polinomials it is sort of intuitive but
for this class of functions it's a bit
non-intuitive. I don't have the time to
explain why this happens since it's it's
not that hard but it's it's a bit
non-intuitive but nevertheless this
simple elementary construction is good
enough to learn any any function. So
what does that mean that I can find a
parameter theta bar? So here uh coming
back to the question of one of your
colleagues I need the identity right
because uh if I just use the positive
part then what happens is I cannot
approximate functions which have
negative parts right so I need the
identity I need that linear layer at the
end so I need the identity and then as
long as it is there I set a tolerance or
you tell me a tolerance somewhere in
these parameters so now you have
converted an infinite dimensional
problem the functions live in infinite
dimensions but these parameters that are
there. These are finite dimensional
objects, right? So you can even count
the dimension. So there always exists
these kind of theta bar such that of
course these number of parameters could
go to infinity. This is uh this is
necessary such that you can approximate
them and it's not just continuous
functions means you can also replace it
by measurability. So measurability is a
very very weak category. So
there is [clears throat] a mathematical
definition anyone who is a mathematician
knows it but essentially roughly
speaking if you can write something or
think of something it's measurable in
anything is measurable any discontinuous
function that you know is measurable
there are non-measurable functions but
they are they they're few and far
between. So the point is as long as
there is some sense of a function an
input output response a neural network
is going to approximate it you you can
find it and what is what is interesting
is that you don't even need this deep
construction one hidden layer is enough
so this is even though I said deep
neural networks there's nothing deep
about it it's enough to just restrict it
to one so capital K can be one so what
does it mean so in the sense that uh you
can have a
You can have a C1 FI then you can have a
scalar nonlinearity then you can have a
C2 so this is essential and your sigma
zero can be identity
and this is good enough and this was
already shown by many people in the late
80s Ceno
Baron many many people and they they
said that this is a good thing because
with we can learn anything because this
is what we want to learn right we want
to learn complex physical relationships
steps between temperature and pressure
or between I don't know velocity and
displacement whatever now we can do that
in principle there exists the capacity
of these objects to be able to
approximate anything okay just like
polomials can approximate any continuous
or any any function any integraable
function essentially these guys can
approximate any measurable function so
this is quite uh quite a remarkable fact
in some sense so we don't need any
additional construction Right. So this
is uh this is an important point. Are
there questions on this? Because this is
I'm not going to explain this any
further. If someone is interested how
this is done, you you [clears throat]
can come to me and I can try to explain
it during the break for instance. Any
questions on this? No clear. So this is
the starting point. Each time you come
up with a construction
probably you want to change the fine
part of it. Probably you want to change
the activation. This is not true for any
activation. There are some conditions.
Activation
essentially is not a polomial.
Activation function
is not a polomial.
So this is uh there are some there are
some details here that I don't want to
explain but don't have the time to
explain but essentially for all these
activation functions that we we saw done
hyperbolic relu
all of them are fine. Okay, sigmoid all
of them are fine. So in principle you
have the capacity of these objects to
learn anything in principle right but
the problem is that it's uh we know that
there exist so this is a typical
mathematician's result there exists a
parameter theta bar for which or theta
yeah theta bar for which we have this
approximation but how are we going to
find it right means it's sort of we know
that it exists but we need to find it
and this is where the entire process of
learning sort of condenses itself too
that we to find this efficiently. Okay.
So this is what I said here. How to
efficiently find the parameter theta bar
you can find it or any approximation
theta hat such that this relationship
holds because at the end of the day we
are going to learn this function. We
know that there exists a parameter
corresponding to which the neural
network is going to approximate this
function. But how to find it right? It's
really like finding a needle in a
haststack as as you will see. So this is
good to have these kind of results. If
these results are not there, then this
would be who knows, right? It would be a
sort of useless pursuit. You don't even
know if you can find what you're
searching for. But at least now we know
that there exists a target and
potentially we can find the target or
potentially we can find many targets.
But let me take a break at this stage
and then after we get back I'm going to
sort of explain a little bit about how
to find this and let's meet at 10. Okay.
So it's uh about 12 minutes of break.
Okay. So let's uh essentially start
where we left which is how do we find we
know that there exists a parameter
weights and biases in this particular
case such that any function can be
approximated right by neural networks by
even one layer shallow as they called
MLPS but how do we find this right this
is uh there's no constructive procedure
in this uh proofs for instance so what
do we do so this finding these
parameters say that the function itself
can be approximated is sort of the core
of what is called supervised learning
is jargon right there's nothing
fundamental about it and it relies on
what is called uh some availability of
data so let me try to explain this
entire pipeline so that you can already
in the exercises you have seen this and
in the next exercise on Monday in the
tutorial you'll see more of this so what
what remember what is the objective
right so here The objective is that
there is a map f right for simplicity I
took R but there's nothing nothing
specific about R here it could be any
highdimensional input output space let's
let's put it as R O okay so O can be
anything including uh one so this is a
ground truth in some sense this the
underlying map we want to approximate
this we know that there exists a neural
network which can do the job right but
the question is how can we find those
parameters. So the point that we try to
do is that first of all so we have a
mapping right it's a mapping from RD to
RO and what we need is what is called
label data
okay so this is the key without this
data we cannot just randomly learn this
uh we can be lucky of course but we have
to we have to find a way to learn it and
what is this label data this is very
very important so the input again I'm
sorry that I changed the notation a
little it but uh because I had zed
somewhere and now it's y but I have
already prepared the slides so I can't
change them here I'll change it in the
next next version so what is what is
going on here so you have an input space
y think of this input space uh right
here so this is your y it's a vector
space uh subset of RD and then what
we're going to do is we're going to
assume that there is a distribution an
input distribution a probability measure
so This mu is a probability measure on
this y. So this is a input distribution.
It could be gaussian, it could be
non-gausian, it could be uniform,
whatever. And based on this
distribution, there exists points. So
let me use another color some points. So
this is a higher dimensional
distribution, right? So these points
I'll label them as yi. Okay. So this is
my my my sort of points input points
that I can sample from. And what is this
fi? I think I didn't define it anywhere
but I can write it down. Z fi is nothing
but f of yi
okay plus some noise epsilon i ep
epsilon i belongs to some some
distribution let's say new and this is
you can think of it as noise okay this
is typically gausian right it's some
sort of white noise so what am I saying
here what I'm saying here is that I have
some access to the system I'm not just
shooting in the dark I have some access
to the system and this access to the
system is provided by being able to
measure or probe the system. I have some
physical system, biological systems, I
don't know internet or whatever, social
network, whatever be the system that I'm
looking at. I'm able to probe the system
at some probe points and these probe
points this could be capital N number of
probe points. I'm assuming that these
points are chosen IID. You know what IID
is independent? So each of these are
independently chosen and identically
distributed. Statistics is all based on
this iid assumption. Um this is an
idealization. In practice it not be the
case, right? But this a good
idealization to have. So I take this
random points. I choose this and I probe
the system in the sense that I can
measure my map on these points. I don't
know explicitly what this map is because
then why do I need to learn it?
But I can I can measure it and then I
say that there is a little bit of noise
which is added to the any measurement is
going to have some measurement parts
right in in in practice later on we are
going to say that there is no noise but
whatever I'm going to say applies to
things with a little bit of noise. So
you take a take take the system you
probe it at these probe points you make
slightly noisy measurements of these
probe points and this provides you with
a data set. So this label data is what
will be our data set. So machine
learning is all about having this nice
label data sets. Okay. So for instance,
chat GPT has been trained on internet
scale data sets. But uh this is this is
how it is. And as I said, other choices
might be necessary in some context means
this iid might not be a relevant
assumption and so on. In practice,
someone gives you the data. As a data
scientist, someone else gives you the
data, but some of the fun is in being
able to generate the data. Right? So you
have this. Okay, here I have to add an
epsilon. I see that I added it here. So
this is a this is what is available to
you data set training set. Some people
also call it as training set. So this is
just these points that uh and these
measurements that we have. So we have
these outputs yi f_i and using these
outputs or using these training data we
are going to learn the map f using the
neural networks f theta. So this is the
training process. Is is there any
question about this data set or training
set as I called it? Everyone understood
what is happening here.
Yeah. Okay. So again people on zoom you
can ask me questions to the chat. If I
see it I'm I'm more than happy to
answer. So we assume without this
machine learning cannot happen. So we
assume that there is an existence of a
data set where these properties are
satisfied. Okay. And the number of
samples that we get it depends on the
problem that you look at. You know some
extreme cases that I have worked with
there are three three of these
measurements. What will you learn from
that? But the three measurements but
then on the other hand you have the
internet scale data sets that chat GPD
or Gemini or all these big llama these
are trained on right so there's a whole
spectrum of the size the diversity the
type of this data set. So we have been
given this uh data we we want to find a
function such that it makes this best
fit to this data. How do we do that? So
this is the yes go ahead
>> you can ask. So say that you're
developing system for
>> how does this uh independent ind
>> in experiments it's very difficult to
guarantee that right so it's very very
difficult to guarantee that because uh
you generally you you can so for the
specific question that you asked about
air foils you know air foils are given
by certain parameters Okay, we will I
don't have the picture today, but in the
in the I think in the previous lecture
we had maybe we even have it. This a
good
I think I had a picture of air
somewhere, right? So let's let's answer
that question.
It's only a finite speed at which I can
move. That was the full aircraft.
But um yeah, there you go. So since you
asked this question about air foils I
can give an answer. So what happens with
air foils is that typically you have a
base air foil right everyone starts with
some base and then you have some
parameters which whatever which sort of
specify the shape. So as I said in the
last lecture these are like 24 or 36
parameters. Let's say that these are 24
par parameters.
These are not the parameters of your
neural network. Right? So of course when
you're simulating it it's no problem.
You can just randomly sample these 24
parameters within a range. But even when
people do experiments, they are not
doing experiments randomly, right? They
need to choose these parameters in a
certain manner. So you can also choose
them uh essentially randomly in that
sense from that set. But the in a design
process no one does it because it's very
expensive. So you take the simulation
data and if the simulation data
indicates that something's optimal, you
go and test it in the effort. you not
test random designs. So experimental
data as you said very correctly need not
satisfy these assumptions. That's why I
said that other choices might be
necessary and this is an idealized
assumption. Right? But it's not
essential that this be randomly
distributed. It's not it's it's good and
you can have mathematical guarantees in
case it is identically distributed but
it's not essential that it be
identically distributed. Sometimes it's
even detrimental that it's identically
distributed. Okay, further questions
that that was a good point. So now how
do we sort of uh square the circle here?
I know that I don't have access to this
guy, right? This is in the dark. I have
access here out here and I want to
determine the theta such that I have a
fit or I'm as close as possible to my f.
So what we do is um standard statistics
you people le these squares is an
example of this there's nothing specific
to neural networks any kind of
statistical learning happens in the same
way
so as you can see here I've just assumed
that the noise is zero but anything that
can be done with zero noise can be done
with small noise and this is this is the
way it is so we have this label data
yi right
and idea is that for any any parameter
any of these weights and biases of
course given this yi so this is the
training data I can always evaluate uh
the fstar theta now I change the
notation again but uh yeah so it is just
the output of the neural network right
so this is I can always evaluate my
neural network it's a it's a function
it's a continuous function I can
evaluate it anywhere so I can evaluate
it of course with some random values of
parameters I'm not going to match the
data set at all. I'm not going to match
the training data. Right? So I will have
a regret, a mismatch or a loss as it is
called. And then the idea is to minimize
the loss. That's it. So in other words,
just think of it conceptually. I have
some data. These are my probe points.
These are the response of the system to
the probe points. I evaluate my neural
network at these points. They are not
going to be exact because if they were
exactly zero, the difference between the
two, this is perfect. But there's never
going to be there's going to be a loss,
a mismatch and I'm going to just
minimize it. I'm going to say that my
neuronet network is going to fit my data
as well as it can. Right? So this is the
objective and the loss functions. This
is some norm or some distance on these
uh on this regret or this mismatch
typically and this is by no means
universal because in natural language
processing or in image classification
you use something else. We'll come to
that later on in the lecture. But uh the
simplest that we can do is we can put a
LP type loss function. Right? So what do
I do at each of these points? I measure
the distance of the regret. Right? This
distance of the regret. I take the
absolute value because otherwise things
will cancel out. Right? So I need to
take an absolute value and then I weigh
it with this P. This can be one or two.
For instance, two is very common because
we are always used to le squares. So,
think of P equal to two is le squares
essentially as it is written here. This
is le squares. So, then I take this at
all the measurement points. I take a sum
and then I normalize right. So, this is
it. And then I want to minimize this
object. So, you usually people take P
equal to two but you can also take P
equal to 1. Then it is what is called
the mean absolute error. And this is
where you sort of induce some sparity
into your system. But you can there
there are many choices here. Okay. But
these are the simplest possible choices.
Already in the course I think later on
we'll see some slightly different
choices. So that's it. So now we know
that what our target is our target is to
be as close to the target function as
possible at these probe points. And to
do that we measure the correct we
measure the difference and we norm it
and we try to minimize the yes
>> uh=
>> uh intuitive is um how do I say this
intuitive is probably hard
uh essentially if you think in terms of
distributions you are going to reduce
the median you know you're going to
reduce to the median and the median
somehow measures
I can give you a mathematical proof but
can I give you the intuition why this is
uh let let me see if I can because
remember that uh the le the le squares
is like a circle right
whereas the this L1 the this one is like
what is happening here
it's doing something fancy [laughter]
okay let me so L1's is more like this
and when you try to intersect a hyper
plane any kind of a hyper plane
you will get sort of many zeros when you
try to induce it maybe that's a
geometric explanation but I don't know
how clear it is maybe you can talk to me
afterwards and I can I can tell you how
how it is so these are different choices
and it's just L1 and L2 it can be
anything you know it's there's a lot of
choice here so now so we have a target.
We know that we have the data. We know
that we have a form to minimize, a
target to minimize and all that we are
left with is how to minimize it. So this
is it. So this is training. Training of
neural networks is essentially just
trying to minimize this objects. Okay.
So what is J? Did I define it as a J?
Yes. So J is my loss function. And loss
is precisely these differences measured
at all the measurement points squared or
taken as an absolute value normalized
right summed and normalized. And then
what I'm going to do is to find the
parameter such that this object is going
to be minimized. And if I can find a
minimum or an approximate minimum, we'll
never be able to find a minimum. If I
can find an approximate minimum, then
that is going to be my train neuronet
network. And the idea is that at least
on these target points it is as close as
possible to my loss or to my ground
truth. Right? So this is it. So I know
that this can be in principle as small
as possible this regret because there
exists there. So the global minimum
global minimum
is given by some theta bar. Remember
that there is a theta bar such that or
it's at least bounded by theta bar such
that this far of theta bar
y minus f of y in whatever norm that
you're choosing is less than whatever
epsilon right so I know that there
exists a target for this minimization
process I may not be able to find it
you'll see in a second why but at least
I can target it towards this so this is
this is training you have data you have
your neural network and you're going to
match the two on these data points.
That's it. And how do we do it? It comes
in a second. But all neural network
training is based on this very very
simple idea. Right? But how do we solve
this minimization problem? First of all,
this is a very very complex problem.
Okay? Why is this a complex problem?
Look at the structure of the problem and
is there any question about this now?
>> Yes.
function. Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh I wouldn't do it because it's very
hard to optimize but it's it's a viable
option. Any any norm is a viable option
but it's very hard. There there there
are some benefits of having the infinity
norm but it's very hard to optimize. So
you have to anyway regularize it. uh I
see a few regularizations but I I
wouldn't ask you to do that because it's
not so easy to solve the optimization
problem. No any norm is fine but sort of
there are there are advantages and
disadvantages with different norms.
Further questions? No. Okay. So then
let's uh try to see how to do this
right. So why is this a very hard
problem? So remember that this theta so
what is this? What is the dimension of
this theta? It depends on what you're
doing, right? So the smallest neural
networks that you guys are going to use
in the course will be in the order of
thousands. Okay? The smallest ones will
be in the order of thousands. In my lab,
the largest neural networks that we work
with, so theta is now in the order of
dimension of theta is like in the order
of thousands. Okay, this is the minimum
that you're going to use maybe. Yeah, I
don't think you'll be below a thousand.
You'll see in a sec how big it is going
to be. In my lab the biggest ones that
we do is a billion. Okay. So this is the
dimension is a billion. So dimension of
theta is a billion. But we routinely
work with 10 billion to a billion. So
anywhere in that range. So this is 10 ^
9 right? But chart GPT is who knows what
is the range of chart GPT? No one knows
right because it's a secret. But uh
people say it's in the trillions right?
So this is another three orders of
magnitude. So remember that these
numbers are just gargantuan. They're
really really big. So that is your
theta. So theta can be at least a
thousand dimensional very very easily.
You cannot work with a 10 dimensional
neural network. This does does not
really work. So usually even a simple
neural network is in thousand dimensions
and all production grade is in millions.
Okay. Nothing nothing is below a
million. So these are very very and of
course it goes all the way to a trillion
the largest ones. So now your theta is
going to be a very very large
dimensional uh object right. So the loss
landscape where you do the minimization
is going in a horrendously very very
large dimensional space. The second and
this is the most important point is that
this J is going to be non-convex in
theta. Now who can tell me why? Because
if you think of it here it's a norm. It
seems like it's a square. and seems like
it's convex. So where is the
non-convexity coming from? Who is going
to tell me why is this a non-convex? Why
is theta going theta going to j of theta
a nonconvex function? Quick argument.
Who wants to say it?
Come on, be brave.
Yes, try
>> in general. So this is only convex. Of
course, it's a norm. It's only convex in
like this argument itself right f minus
f theta but remember what goes into the
theta it's it's a very very complex
object so it's highly highly nonconvex
activation functions even the aphine
layer even if there was no activation
function this is uh unless until you
have too many complexities right you
have the aine layer activation for sure
makes it nonconvex to begin with and
very very complex so you should write
down for a very simple system how this
optimization problems look like. So
you'll see that it is a very very so
it's nonconvex. If it was a convex
optimization problem then we know that
we could reach the global minimum right
but if it's non-convex all bets are off.
So it's a very very high dimensional
non-convex and highly non-convex. There
are lots of local minima local maxima.
Earlier I used to show the lo loss
landscape because it's difficult to
visualize it in some cases but it's a
very very complex problem. So this is
why this optim this is why if you are
able to do this at scale uh Mark
Zuckerberg is paying you how many 100
million or whatever he's paying right
the best people in machine learning are
those who can deal with this
optimization problem and they know how
to they know with the art how they can
deal with it but this is a very very
formidable challenge. You'll see when
you try to train neural networks that
they're extremely sensitive to choices
and when you make one choice they work
well make a slightly different choice
they don't work well and this is because
of this non-convex optimization so if
you take cuts uh along maybe I can you
know maybe here so if you take some cuts
this could be the loss landscape could
be something let's use red it could be
there is a local minimum but then there
is some sharp hills valley something
like this it looks horren
why did this just for maybe it was too
oscilly for something like this. So if
you are anywhere here you might be
trapped in local minimum you can go to
the next valley who knows this is a very
very complex complex shape. So how can
we do this? There are different ways in
which this minimization problem can be
solved but almost all of them are based
on gradient descent. Right? So if you
just learned calculus, basic calculus
analysis 1 and two and someone says how
do you optimize or how do you minimize a
function? You learn about gradient
descent. You just look at the landscape,
look at where the steepest uh descent is
and move along the steepest descent.
What is that? So that is simply a
iterative method, right? I'm hurrying
[clears throat] up a little bit because
I I need to cover some things. So it's a
iterative method. uh as you can see here
L is the iteration step and all that you
do is that you move in the direction of
the negative gradient. So you compute
the gradient. So this tells you
directions in your loss landscape and
you take the negative the steepest
negative direction and you move along
that. So if your function is convex it
is guaranteed to go to a global minimum
after X number or L number of steps. If
if it does if it is not convex what can
happen? it will go into a local minimum
and it can be trapped there for instance
right so this is uh this is the curse of
dealing with non-convex optimization so
this ectile is the learning rate because
it depends on how big and how small
steps you take and this is very very
important in neural network training you
will see already probably in the
tutorial last this week and in the next
week this will be covered quite
extensively how this uh learning rate
has to be varied [snorts] okay so now we
know that it converges to a local
minimum at best means uh you you cannot
expect convergence to a global minimum
and you just march in the direction of
the uh steepest negative descent right
so this is so you you need to compute
gradients and this is this is going to
be an issue so uh what am I going to say
here so as I said so the loss function
itself has this uh component-wise form
right so it's a sum so this I said is ji
so each each point I point it
contributes to the loss function. So
when I compute the gradient then uh the
gradient is a loss is a sum so it gets
aggregated. So you have this uh
relationship here and so this means that
you have to compute this gradient for
many many many points. Now just imagine
for the internet scale data sets with
these large networks how expensive this
is going to be right. So that's why it's
uh slow. This gradient computation is
slow. It's very very memory intensive.
You have to store many things. So this
is uh this is not an optimal way to do
this. Uh so gradient descent is just an
idealized way. No one does gradient
descent. Okay. So what instead people do
and is to take what is called stoastic
gradient descent. By the way, this is a
simple picture that is very often used
to explain what's going on.
This is convex optimization right
because um this is the best that you can
do but you can think of it as a local
local landscape and so these contours
are uh the different levels of the
functions so each of these contours is J
equal to some I don't know JL or
something like that so this is at a
smaller smaller smaller smaller smallest
right so it's like a valley that you are
you're moving in and gradient descent
all that it does is that you follow the
direction the negative ative gradient go
to the next level follow the negative
gradient go to the next level and then
you converge. Okay. So this is this is
very very good but it's expensive it is
slow it's very very memory intensive. So
what an alternative is to do what is
called stochastic there are some other
benefits to it is to do what is called
stoastic gradient descent because anyway
these problems are noisy. So what is
done in stoastic gradient descent is
that instead of choosing all these
directions to march down all the
directions you just take one direction
it's an extreme but you take one
direction in each step of course you
have many many many different steps and
then you just compute the loss so it's a
very very poor approximation but it's an
approximation to the total gradient and
there is some convergence theory and so
on and eventually you can prove that it
will also go to a global minimum for a
convex function but the direction is
very very noisy but remember now my
computation becomes uh super easy right
earlier I was computing this for I don't
know thousand points or 10,000 points or
whatever now I'm computing it for one
point I have to take a lot of steps but
each time it's one point so my memory
consumption goes down my compute goes
down and so on and so forth but it has
very high variance it has a very noisy
convergence and the picture is this that
it starts doing some walks it moves out
moves in moves out but eventually if you
have small enough steps you're going to
converge. So what one does is to balance
these two and this is what you are going
to do in the course and this is called
the mini match gradient descent or mini
match optimization which is given by
this picture here which is that you're
going to do some random sufficients
and you're going to divide them into
batches. Okay, you're going to divide
them into batches and then this is best
explained practically. So when Bdan is
going to do the tutorial, I'll ask him
to explain it. So you do this. So
instead of marching along every step,
you march along a few steps. So instead
of having thousand uh points, you march
along I don't know 10 points or 50
points in each time. So next time
another set of 50 points, next time
another set of 50 points and so on. And
you can recover if you take the full
batch you get gradient descent. If you
get just one then you get stoastic
gradient descent. This way you can get
um what is called mini batch. So the
computation is balanced and there is the
noise is also reduced. So eventually you
converge. So this is another
hyperparameter the so-called batch size.
So this is uh so so this so another
batch size each of size n. So this is
what is called the batch size.
So learning rate, batch size, these are
very very important terms that that you
need to adjust. But this goes into the
sort of lore of machine learning
somehow. Okay. But uh the point is that
in practice you don't you use many
batches or batches but you never use
stoastic gradient descent by itself.
There are more fancy. So, so modern
optimizers
this is a choice that this is a whole
course you know there's a course called
optimization machine learning which is
offered in the computer science
department where they tell you different
kinds of optimizers but the most modern
optimizer most heavily used optimizer is
something called Adam
okay adaptive moment estimation I really
don't have the time to explain it but uh
when you do your practical work you will
see that it has some advantages over
just pure gradient descent So almost all
the modern optimizers including the ones
that train large language models are
based on some variant of atom. Okay. But
this is just a fancy way to compute
gradients and to use them in this mini
batch manner. The root is still stoastic
gradient dec. Okay. Good. So then uh
just to just to finish the story a
little bit uh so there are different
choices that you can make. So remember
that this is a iterative process. Maybe
I can write it here. So it's an
iterative process right here. So this is
your std or mini batch iteration but it
has to start right. So starts with
at theta 0. So usually and you'll see at
the very end of my lectures that the
choice of this theta 0 is going to be
changed but usually we start with
something which is random.
So this is uh often random because
that's the best choice.
Okay. And then there are some
normalizations and so on. This will
again be explained to you. But
essentially if you change the random
points remember that this is totally
non-convex. So of course where you
converge where you go depends on where
you start with. Right? So just imagine
that you have some function which is
non-convex
and it depends a little bit where you
start. If you start here clearly you'll
go to this minimum. If you start for
instance here you'll probably go to this
minimum. Right? And it's very difficult
to escape this big local minima. you can
escape some small local minima perhaps
because there is noise so you can go to
the next one but here so everything
depends on where you start in some sense
that's why it's very sensitive so what
people do is that they start with
multiple starting values and see if your
results depend on the starting values so
if your process is stable and your
training is well done then it should not
depend too much on these starting values
because otherwise you're just using too
much of the of the stoasticity inherent
in this process. So this is this an
important point that I wanted to make.
Another important point that I want to
make is how do we know that our training
is successful right mean this is a again
there can be a full course on this
particular topic which is to do with
generalization but let me just state uh
what what we can do. So what we can do
is we can always monitor the training
loss. So what is the training loss?
Training loss was 1 / L of f of yi minus
f* of theta of yi something like this.
This is the object that we have access
to because we have ground truth. We can
evaluate how good we are. Right? But our
objective is to go here. Right? And as
you can see this guy it looks like a
loose approximation of this guy. So this
is an approximation to this. This
approximates it. Right? You can see that
this is an integral. This is some sort
of a sum. It's a Monte Carlo sum. It's
it's more or less that. And then what we
want to go is to look at the
generalization error. And the for those
who have seen le squares, you can always
overfit. You know, you can you can
always overfit because these are highly
underparameterized or over parameterized
depending on the problem that you have.
So one has to be very very careful. The
idea is not to get the smallest uh
error. It's not overfit to the data but
is to really minimize this
generalization error or error on unseen
data and the practical way to do it
there's a lot of theory behind it and
during the course we are going to sort
of deal with this in in some to some
extent but at this level at a first
level the way we do this in practice is
to use what is called a validation set
right so training set and validation set
are independent of each other this is
again this measured uh validation Z let
me call it as Z I perhaps
or Z J maybe which contained in Y. So
these are some independent points where
you can probe the system and you can
measure the response of the system and
you see how well your network does on
these validation points and everyone
does this. So you whatever data you have
you take 90% of it for your training and
5 to 10% of it on your validation just
to see that your network is not
overfitting to the data. It is capturing
something more about the function and
not just about the data. So this is a
practical way to deal with this problem
but again I think this will be covered
in the in the tutorials. So I think uh
more or less this is all I wanted to say
about training. There are many many as I
said these are full courses right but we
are not here to learn about machine
learning we are here to learn about
machine learning applied to the problems
that we have in mind which is what we'll
do from the next lecture right so the
steps are very simple we have
constructed neural networks we know
about label data and we know about how
to train very roughly in 15 minutes that
I covered in 20 minutes
we know how to train these neural
networks so that they can hit the target
essentially Right. But uh there are
there's a lot more to it and I say it's
impossible with the limited time that I
have to cover these topics. This is what
is covered in your introduction to
machine learning and advanced machine
learning courses here at ETH but uh
perhaps elsewhere. Okay. So there's one
point that I want to make which is uh I
know that I was very quick but this is
on purpose. So please go to the tutorial
uh and also follow the tutorial from
this week and go to the tutorial next
week where more of this is going to be
done. They're going to explain the
practical way in which uh you can train
neural networks. Uh I know I was too
quick but if you have a quick question
I'm happy to cover it.
No questions
when you learn uh the practical things
you can come and ask me questions after
that. So there's one final point that I
want to make which is uh this will be
done in the next tutorial. So I give you
a little bit of a preview. So the point
is that uh what are these fully so
remember what is an MLP roughly speaking
you have this composition but it is
sigma w z + v right each layer is like
this. So this is a scalar nonlinearity
this is your weight matrix and this is
your y.
Now the point is that uh what is the
size of these matrices and why they tend
to be very very large right. So if you
take an image so this is a typical
example of an image and we will deal
with similar kind of problems for what
we are doing. So if you take an image
like this image of a car but this could
also be the image of a pressure field.
So this is uh at a very low resolution
even at a very low resolution this is
essentially a 70 372 dimensional vector
why is that because it is u is it 64 by
what is the because it's clearly three
channels right so this is24
so 32x 32 it's a very very coarse
resolution but still even with a very
coarse resolution of the number of
pixels you get a vector if you stack it
or if you lend the net it will be a
vector straight net it will be a vector
which is 3,72 dimensions so this is your
input this is your u
I don't understand why theta okay m is
very large but anyway so this is your
input right so this is your input
dimension dimension of this already is
3,000 dimensional right so this is very
very and let me give you a scale when
we're going to look at 3D data sets this
is going to be million dimensions
because these are really really large so
we'll deal with million dimensional
inputs. Now remember if this matrix is a
full matrix so this is 372 dimension I
want to map it to 372 dimensions. So
this is essentially a 3,000x 3,000
matrix a single matrix right and that is
9 million right say 3,000 to 3,000 is 9
million and just imagine if you have 10
layers you have 90 million so this
already very very quickly becomes a very
very large problem so you don't keep
this and similarly the bias vector but
that is tiny compared to the weight
matrix just imagine storing a matrix
which is of the order of 10 million each
time there's already you need a pretty
big GPU for that. Right? So very early
on no one uses uh the full structure of
this matrix. No one uses one has to sort
of put in some systemic information what
are called inductive biases.
In the machine learning literature these
are called inductive biases. These are
essentially giving some domain specific
information such that your complexity
can be reduced because already very very
quickly it's a milliondimensional matrix
and you have many million dimensional
matrices you are anyway cooked right so
you need some some sort of reduction you
need some sort of uh complexity
reduction and one very very powerful
complexity reduction technique there are
many so there are many structures to it
so beyond MLPS the first one that is
widely used already from the 1980s These
is what are called convolutional neural
networks or CNN's. These were
essentially explored or developed I
don't know how you call it by Leam. So
Yan Leam
who won the Turing award right he's
considered to be one of the godfathers
of AI he was the person who sort of
maybe he didn't invent it but he was the
person who certainly exploded the most
in the 1980s. So he's he's famous for
this and the idea is instead of using
some and we are going to revisit this
because we also need this kind of
inductive biases but I just wanted to
give you an example that you never take
a full matrix here. So this matrix now
reduces to a convol or the operation
reduces to a convolution instead of a
matrix vector multiplier. So this is a
discrete convolution and this is instead
of matrix vector multiply instead of a
naive
a z right a z is a matrix vector
multiplier so what you do in a discrete
convolution is that you take a matrix
okay so let's look at some structure
if you think want to think of it in
matrix terms so you take I don't know
let's take let's say that it's a very
simple convolution with three elements
so you have
C min -1 C 0 C1 C min -1 C 0 C Now it's
not even writing C 0 C1 and lots of
zeros elsewhere right
so you end up with what are called
circulent matrices
or sparse matrices just for simplicity
let's say sparse matrices
so the convolution is one way in which a
discrete convolution instead of a matrix
vector multiply This sparsifies the
matrix tremendously, right? So instead
of working with milliondimensional
matrices, you work with a small vector.
You know it's a 9,000 dimensional vector
because there are just three components.
So we are going to revisit this in our
course and on Monday next Monday we pop
and shen they are going to sort of
introduce you to this. So this is one
way to reduce complexity and all these
architectures are ways to reduce
complexity and this is a
characterization a picture of that. So
instead of having a full matrix you
replace it with discrete convolution
still use a relu. So discrete
convolution relu discrete convolution
relu and then this pooling is some sort
of another sparse matrix sparer matrix
okay it's some down sampling we'll cover
that. So what all that I'm trying to say
is I'm not going to explain convolutions
today. I'll do it later in the course.
But the point is that you take some
structure you put some structure and
inductive bias on this matrix. And based
on this you have CNN's but these are
just some of the architectures that we
are going to see. You have recurrent
neural networks recurrent neural
networks. These have a different
structures time series structure. You
have graph neural networks which we will
cover. You have transformers which is
the most common ones now which we'll
cover state space models.
There's so many different and all of
these are structured ways in which you
apply the nonlinearity but more
importantly in which you work with this
matrix. Okay. So we are going to cover
different examples of it. All that I'm
trying to say is that there's life
beyond MLPS and we will we'll come to
that fairly quickly. So I think it's
important to go to the lecture on the
tutorial on Monday because they're going
to cover CNN's. They're going to help
you how a CNN is going to classify an
image and in four lectures we are going
to see how a CNN is going to enable us
to learn the temperature distribution or
the displacement distribution for some
physical system and you'll see that
there is a lot of analogs. I think with
this I stop here a bit early but in the
next lecture we will change gears and
we'll see already how these objects can
be used for physical systems. Okay, I
stop here.